-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#SpringBreakInSixWords responses
from you guys.
This first one is
from @sophiardicapua.
She says, "10 college kids
one motel room."
Hey, I've been there.
[ Laughter ]
"I got the bathtub."
This one is from
@Michelle06172431.
That rolls off the tongue there.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
No, I --
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't do it,
but I really wanted to do it
Can I do this?
-Yeah, I'm doing this
to itch my nose.
-Yeah.
That buzzer came
a little too quick.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Guess what. They're on it.
-Bumming me out.
-Yeah.
-I think they have
something against me.
-Well, they want you
to be healthy.
-This is from @Michelle06172431.
She says,
"How did sand get in there?"
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-We know how it got in there
This one is
from @clearwaters.
-Nice.
-They say, "Down for a vacation,
leaving on probation."
Hey, that's --
[ Laughter ]
Better than jail.
This one is from @chickatie.
-Oh, she's chic. Say "chic."
-She says, "Please don't tag m
on Facebook."
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Smart, that's a smart thing.
This one is from @roninthekey.
He says, "How I learned abou
credit scores."
Well, there you go, yeah.
This one is from @dfwheat.
-@Dfwheat?
-@Dfwheat.
Did you ever meet anyone wit
the last name wheat?
-No, never.
Wheat.
[ Laughter ]
-I would say
that's the Russian bot.
-Yeah, that's probably the bot
'cause they'll fool you.
-I mean, I know Buck.
-Buck Wheat?
-Yeah, Buck Wheat
is the only person
I know with
the last name Wheat.
-Yeah, that's it.
-Yeah.
Oh, Cream Of --
-Cream of, did you say?
-Yeah.
Cream of Wheat.
[ Laughter ]
-Hi, this is my friend Cream of.
That's a Russian name, Creamof
[ Laughter ]
My name is Creamof.
-"Creamof."
-"Creamof Wheat."
-No, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
She says, "Coronavirus isn't
the only contagious thing!
Oh, boy.
[ Audience ohs ]
-"Hello!
Fist bump."
-This one is from
@alicenwonderland.
She says, "And nine months
later, you arrived."
[ Audience ohs ]
That's it.
Last one is from @matthewtsang
He says, "Shots, shots, shots,
shots, shots, shots!"
There you have it.
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags